está en riesgo la democracia
estadounidense cómo lo vio usted
Claro que sí están juego en el sentido
de que tuvimos una
corrupción completamente del sistema
norteamericano y aprendimos que hay
mucho no escrito pero son traiciones que
vivimos en democracia norteamericana No
hemos hecho una reforma electoral por lo
cual hay mucha gente dentro de los
Estados Unidos que está pidiendo esa
reformas electorales pero tuvimos por
ejemplo de incidencia de una violencia
otra vez con las representantes de Nancy
polossi en con su esposo justamente su
casa ahí en California entonces no
estamos tan tan lejanos de lo que fue el
6 de enero Entonces estamos
Sobreviviendo y hoy en la noche esa
noche muy especial porque tenemos muchos
muchos casillas que están al juego no no
se sabe cómo va a resolver Y eso va a
terminar mucho de democracia no
solamente hoy en día sino también en el
lanzamiento posible de ambos candidatos
de republicanos y demó pero también Y
qué va a pasar en vez de cuatro Entonces
no son hoy es no solamente una noche de
democracia pero también esa noche de
verse Cómo se va a resolver muchos
asuntos democráticos para 20 y 24